c'est l'actif le plus précieux des
agriculteurs pourtant on l'a longtemps
ignoré et encore aujourd'hui on le
connaît mal je vous parle évidemment du
sol qui nous rentrent innombrables
services comme de nourrir des milliards
d'êtres humains sur la terre chaque jour
pourtant les sols ne se porte pas bien
il est grand temps qu'on prenne soin
d'eux voici notre grand dossier sur la
santé des sols
le sol est essentiel à notre survie
95 % de nos aliments proviennent d'une
mince couche de sol à la surface de la
terre
depuis dix mille ans on le cultive et
nous nourrit mais dans les cent
dernières années l'agriculture s'est
intensifié à vitesse grand v
[Musique]
je
aujourd'hui les sols sont à bout de
souffle
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture la fao
considère que le tiers des terres
agricoles de la planète est déjà
dégradée alors qu'il faut milan pour
régénérer 2 à 3 cm de terre arable
[Musique]
l'agriculture a subi des transformations
très importante surtout en matière de
mécanisation bien sûr petit à petit on
en est arrivé à un système qui est
beaucoup plus artificielle qui est
artificialisé en fait par rapport à ce
qu'on veut trouver dans la nature
à les oliviers est un spécialiste
d'agroécologie on est parti de systèmes
paysans où il y avait une diversité à la
fois de plantes et même d'animaux on
avait une intégration étroite de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage à des
systèmes très spécialisés où on a une
unique culture des dizaines ou même des
centaines d'hectares à la fois aux
villes dix ans les monocultures ont
accéléré la perte de fertilité des sols
des monocultures ça marche ça marche et
évidemment pendant un certain temps ç'a
permis d'avoir un rendement élevé d'une
seule culture ça simplifie beaucoup les
choses en matière de récolte par exemple
mais très vite on s'est rendu compte que
on avait des problèmes de dégradation
des sols par exemple parce qu'on a des
cultures qui exploite toujours la même
couche de sol qui ont le même type
d'investissement
au cours du siècle dernier de nouveaux
produits ont permis au rendement de
faire des bonds de géant les engrais
chimiques des produits adopté à grande
échelle sans qu'on en mesure toujours
les impacts sur le sol on sait peu de
choses de ce qui se passe dans le sol
puis malheureusement bon de jouer un peu
aux apprentis sorciers je dirais
on s'est dit avec les avancées de la
chimie par exemple il suffit d'ajouter
un peu d'azoté un peu de phosphore un
peu de potassium on brasse tout ça on
fait des qualités qu'il faut et puis on
va avoir un bon rendement de la plante
c'est vrai à court terme mais ce dont on
s'est pas rendu compte en fait c'est que
le sol c'est beaucoup plus qu'une
addition d'éléments chimiques c'est un
milieu qui est grouillant de vie c'est
un milieu vivant
pour comprendre de quoi il s'agit ça
vaut la peine de faire un trou et les
regarder de plus près
car olivier gauche et conseille des
agriculteurs en s'inspirant des
principes de l'agroécologie une approche
qui mise entre autres sur l'incroyable
pouvoir des plantes
ici la première vue ça bouge pas on
dirait que rien qui se passe et pourtant
si on regarde avec un microscope
dans une cuillère à soupe qui représente
15 g on peut avoir entre 6 et 9
milliards d'organismes vive
il y a donc plus d'organismes vivants
dans une cuillère et de sol qui lie à
d'êtres humains sur la terre ce qui fait
du sol l'un des plus grands réservoirs
de biodiversité de la planète des
insectes bénéfiques il ya des
micro-organismes bénéfique un paquet de
bactéries de champignons certaines de
ces petites créatures vont décomposer la
matière organique
d'autres sont capables d'extraire les
minéraux de la roche et de les rendre
disponibles pour les plantes d'autres
encore protège les végétaux des
pathogènes et ce ne sont que quelques
exemples de ce qui se passe sous nos
pieds plus on produit de biomasse
aérienne et souterraine plus la
biodiversité augmentant sol plus la
biodisponibilité désigne les éléments
nutritifs va augmenter aussi plus et
biodisponible plus on produit de belles
récoltes de belles couvertures tout est
relié tout est lié les scientifiques
considèrent qu'on ne connaît qu'une
infime partie de tous les micro
organismes du sol mais on sait que leur
équilibre est affecté entre autres par
les engrais et les pesticides le
problème des fongicides et insecticides
c'est qu'ils sont rarement très sélectif
c'est à dire qu'ils vont affecter will
insectes dont on voudrait se débarrasser
affecté le champignon dont on voudrait
se débarrasser mais bon en affecter
aussi plein d'autres organismes qui sont
des organismes utiles
chaque année au canada près 200 millions
de kilogrammes de pesticides sont
utilisés dans les champs cultivés des
produits qui améliorent les rendements à
court terme mais qui se retrouve un peu
partout dans l'environnement et
contaminent notamment les cours d'eau
pourtant il y aurait d'autres façons de
faire
[Musique]
nous sommes à la fin avril les feuilles
commencent à peine à sortir
tous bruns les champs émergent de
l'hiver mais certaines parcelles déjà
verte se démarque ici le seigle forme un
beau tapis
après maints seigle laisser guider par
les pros c'est vrai au printemps c'est
promis qu'ils comprennent
andré charbonneau et producteur laitier
à saint-marc-sur-richelieu depuis une
dizaine d'années il couvre ses champs en
permanence et il ne laboure plus
montre que les plantes font travail
mécanique des arènes en place des
racines faut qu'il y ait plus de vie
dans ces marais en place plus que les
mécaniques ses meilleurs selon moi
on est un peu de vie dans seul tout
l'ensemble répond mieux
selon lui il faut changer notre façon de
voir le sol et faire confiance à sa
fertilité naturelle son travail et sa
dont beaucoup d'engrais chimiques ça
devient comme un support les plans mais
son sens même dingue répond je savais
qu'elle que cela nous donne
toute la sphère rapporte que la hauteur
des besoins
après sa récolte de céréales au mois
d'août l'agriculteur a tout de suite
ressemer des cultures de couverture
arriver à l'automne le mélange multi
espèces et luxuriant grâce à ces plantes
andré charbonneau a pu réduire de moitié
les engrais chimiques sur sa ferme dans
ses champs de maïs on voit aussi comment
les cultures de couverture entre les
rangs barre la voie aux mauvaises herbes
en occupant l'espace ce qui diminue
l'utilisation des pesticides
pour approfondir la question retrouvons
pierre-olivier gauche et sur sa terre à
contrecoeur
elle bien rallier
selon lui il faut de toute urgence
cesser de se battre contre la nature et
essayez plutôt de limiter
un seul coup vance un sol fertile il est
le printemps c'est quoi qu'il va les
gazons les prairies les fossés les bars
de fausser le chanu ne pousse pas ça va
prendre un mois un mois et demi ce temps
photosynthèse lassé de l'énergie pour
qui pour nous et nos employés dans notre
usine qui ne sonne le trio soir la
rhizosphère c'est la zone qui entoure
les racines c'est un lieu d échanges
intenses entre les plantes et les
champignons mycorhiziens notamment les
mycorhizes c'est quoi ces des
champignons qui s'associe aux racines
donc ils cognent à la porte de la racine
is écoute moi j'veux pas capables de
produire de la photosynthèse donc
d'avoir déçu que je changerais déçu
qu'on du territoire je râle expérience
de retour pour toi je suis visé des
éléments nutritifs que t'es pas capable
de se mobiliser
qui on va vivre en symbiose pour on va
bien s'entendre cette alliance va
permettre aux plantes d'avoir accès à
des éléments essentiels à leur
croissance et leur santé comme le
magnésium le calcium lezin tous ces
éléments vont développer un système
immunitaire de planck beaucoup plus
élevé qui va être beaucoup moins
favorisés par la tacc de ravageurs de
champignons de maladies fongiques tout
ça c'est une synergie 3 les arbres à
côté de nous ils sont pratiquement
jamais malade parce qu'une synergie un
écosystème il faut créer l'écosystème
cultiver
pour que ça fonctionne il faut donc
perturber ce milieu là le moins possible
depuis l'antiquité on laboure pour
ameublir le sol et préparer les semis
pendant des siècles on l'a fait avec des
animaux et des outils rudimentaires
aujourd'hui on laboure pour les mêmes
raisons mais la machinerie est beaucoup
plus lourde est autrement plus puissante
ce qui a des conséquences sur tout ce
qui vit dans le sol les galeries des
insectes et des animaux bénéfiques comme
les vers de terre sont détruites des
réseaux de champignons mycorhiziens
déchiré
dès qu'on travaille au sol on brise ses
chaînes de mycorhizes là ils vont se
reformer parce que la nature est
extrêmement résilient mais à mesure
qu'on a un seul qui s'appauvrit qui
devient morts en guinée mais on ne
paquet de carence qui apparaissent dans
les végétaux
pourquoi l'agriculture conventionnelle
u6 les engrais de synthèse et les
pesticides c'est parce que le seul dépôt
vive si les pratiques modernes ont
contribué à nuire aux écosystèmes on
peut désormais penser l'agriculture
autrement et des solutions existent pour
redonner vie aux sols dégradés ce qui
est merveilleux c'est que on peut faire
des écosystèmes cultiver plus que tarbes
et des monocultures avec des chants à nu
entre les reins pourquoi ça fonctionne
quand conflit seul parce qu'on imite la
nature
c'est pas juste une question d'écologie
c'est une question de production aussi
aujourd'hui et demain dans notre projet
futur
[Musique]